so hey everyone again super excited to
introduce Michael steve-o who's a
partner of Y Combinator Michael has done
pretty much everything there is to do in
Silicon Valley came out here 2006 I want
to say to start justin.tv
with a couple of other yayoi's they ran
that for a couple years and then
actually split the company into two one
company with Socialcam which went on to
south autodesk for sixty million dollars
the other one was twitch which sold to a
Mosin
two years ago and then he moved on to be
a full time partner at Y Combinator and
has been you know there's like awesome
stories that I kind of want to get into
the introducing Airbnb to AI Combinator
that justin.tv mafia and there's like so
much more that we can sort of dig into
but I think it's just an honor to be
here
being able to interview Michael so maybe
we could just start with you just give a
little background about you know you're
at Yale
it's like mid 2000s and you graduate and
then like how did you end up in Silicon
Valley so I didn't like going to class
at all I was on the five year plan at
Yale I was kicked out and told to come
back after I figured out how to
participate a little bit more a little
bit less on having fun little bit more
academically I was a Poli Sci major I
can honestly say I academically learned
almost nothing but being kicked out
allowed me to come back to Yale in the
class of 2005 and become friends this
guy named Justin Kahn who comes up with
crazy start-up ideas that was basically
my Yale experience in that show and I
left Yale to work on a political
campaign well I graduated then worked in
a political campaign for a year and then
Justin said he was going to start a
company to broadcast his life 24/7 by
putting a camera on his head and he
asked me if he thought if I thought that
was a good idea yes yeah we were having
dinner with his dad and we both said
that was a really stupid idea
and went on with our lives it turns out
the campaign we've lost we lost by three
percentage points
I was the head fundraiser for the
campaign and it was a US Senate campaign
so I should have really known it wasn't
gonna go well but we almost won and so I
was looking to go on vacation and Justin
had somehow convinced Paul Graham to
give him $50,000 to try putting a camera
on his head and so he and Emmett another
one of our Yale friends were taking a
road trip across the country to start
this company in San Francisco I wanted
to go on vacation so I asked if I could
join on this road trip and they said
sure they didn't tell me that they had
packed all of their belongings in the
car and so if I were to take a seat they
would have to throw away 25% of their
belongings which they did graciously and
I asked what's the plan you know we're
taking a road trip from New York to San
Francisco and they said we're gonna just
get on a tee and drive straight and that
didn't sound like a fun vacation so I
planned this whole vacation we met a
bunch of jelly's along the way and when
we came into the city actually we got
into town almost right around here we
stopped at Treasure Island to look at
the the city in the skyline it was
during the day it was October it was
sunny maybe 75 degrees and the Blue
Angels were practicing over the city and
I'm like this is the best place I've
ever seen in my life but we weren't
gonna live in San Francisco Justin had a
cousin in Mountain View and we were
going to stay in his basement which
sucked so for the next week they're
working on justin.tv I'm hanging out and
I thought maybe I should be helpful so I
decided to help them find an apartment
which ended up becoming a apartment in
this apartment building called Y scraper
which hosted Airbnb no I'm sorry Dropbox
and a whole bunch of
I see companies and I open them up a
bank account and at the end of the trip
they invited me to become a co-founder
of the company and I said no because
this is the stupidest idea I've ever
heard and Justin my dad says Justin's
the best recruiter in the world because
Justin said to me well just think about
it and I can't just like look at someone
in the eye who's just driven to the
airport after two weeks and say no [ __ ]
you like so I say I'm gonna think about
it and in the meantime they recruited
our fourth co-founder Kyle who happens
to be the founder of a company called
crews that just sold for a billion
dollars and they sent me all of Kyle's
kind of elaborate drawings of this
camera he was gonna build and I thought
to myself well it's Justin it's $50,000
they've got this Kyle guy and it's a
great programmer this is pretty much
baked like guaranteed win so I flew back
to the apartment that I found for them
and within three weeks I was sleeping in
the living room and that was 2006 so
like once I you know you had that
$50,000 from Paul Graham had you
launched at that point had you long ago
with nothing okay so like how did you go
from there to hey we've launched a
product to maybe talking about like did
you go back through Y Combinator and
then yeah we were completely
dysfunctional we were like 21 22 22 and
23 we knew nothing we were really stupid
most of the time we basically had to
build a camera like a physical camera
that could stream live video walking
around which was pretty hard and then
this website that could stream video and
none of the like tools existed like AWS
didn't exist so we were racking servers
and all these other like CD ends didn't
support live video there's all these
kind of issues you there were no like
this was pre iPhone there were no like
3G cards there was just none of this
[ __ ] you wouldn't need to do this and so
we started doing YC I guess we we all
kind of moved by January 2007 so we're
in that went
2007 YC class and I remember that YC was
a lot smaller back then I think it was
probably only ten companies in our batch
and PG would call me once a week and say
why haven't you launched the team had
four co-founders and I was the business
guy and I was like I have no idea I'm
ready
these guys I don't know and I'm like why
aren't you calling the people building
the product he called me and so it was
really funny because I later learned
that was like one of the core pieces of
YC advice like pre-launch the only
advice is launch there was like no
nuance there was no like oh what are you
gonna do when you launch or like how
much press are you gonna get I was like
no it was just why haven't you launched
yesterday and so we launched and we
launched by March of that year and that
began a complete [ __ ] show yeah that was
pretty crazy so when did you decide to
sort of transform the idea into more of
a they became a live streaming platform
for other people to come on and sort of
live stream when did you decide like
that was the big bet and then when did
you go on to you know sort of raise
venture and scale it into something a
bit bigger so very quickly we learned
that live video cost a lot of money so
we had to start raising money and so we
had to raise money from these people
called angels who back you know we just
kind of saw them as like rich people
used to work at Google so some of those
people are now kind of you know big
deals so I didn't think it was one of
our investors pabu height the inventor
of gmail as one of our investors Mike
maples partnered with and it's one of
our investors and I think III think we
just told them we were creating an
online reality TV show which is still a
stupid idea and I remember Paul Buchheit
said basically I just want to give you
guys a 25k to see like what will happen
literally like this sounds is crazy they
all made a lot of money by the way so
you know that gave us a little bit of
money to operate
we kind of thought we were funny you
know like we like would hang out in
college and drink and we people thought
we were mildly funny I guess
and so we're like oh that will really
work like on a screen 24 hours a day and
after three months we realized that's
not true nobody cared and so we decided
that maybe other people would be able to
stream video better than we did and
because we had a very technical team of
co-founders and we were all equal
co-founders transitioning from a show to
allowing other people to broadcast was
extremely straightforward I mean there
was a work to do but we didn't have to
hire people or use consultants or any of
that [ __ ] so we got to work and we
started pitching VCS and it was really
funny because all the VCS said no have
probably pitched every single fund that
anyone has ever heard of and they all
said no and we had a whiteboard in our
office which was also our apartment and
on it it had these proposals of like
what we thought these VC firms are going
to give us and had like the name of the
fund and we thought they were going to
give us but this was maybe a month and
half old because all of those funds that
just told us straight up no but we
invited one VC to the office and we
didn't realize that was still up on the
wall and so he thought that we had
offers
so he gave us a term sheet and so we
raised two million dollars and back then
two million dollars was a series a I was
to 1/8 and that got us started yeah if I
can communicate anything of like
intelligence is not a big factor in this
that comes later that comes later is a
lot of luck in the beginning tons of
luck all right so so fast-forward a bit
I think it's like 2010 2011 time frames
I think he'd build justin.tv you'd raise
some more money you built justin.tv to
like like a real business I think you
were you know yeah so by then you know
fast forward a couple years justin.tv is
30 million people coming every month
we're watching some one godly amount of
video you know hundreds and hundreds of
millions video views per month and we're
running low on money we had raised a
series B by that point and we're running
low on money and we're starting to
slowly realize that no one will ever
invest in us and actually two companies
start talking to us about buying us one
was IAC
who decided not to the other was Google
who decided not to and needless to say
both of those prices were way way lawyer
or and with Google was particularly
interesting because we had to send the
whole company to interview at Google
which is really [ __ ] weird to say
like Oh everything is going good but
just everyone we're all going to Google
for the day the interview
yeah but em everything's good
and so Google says no so now we're kind
of in the [ __ ] and so I remember we had
two months of money left we were burning
twenty fifty thousand dollars a month we
were probably making 500k a month and
spending seven hundred fifty K a month
and we had 500 in the back and so we had
to kind of call this meeting where it
was like hey what's the deal and so
remember this meeting our office was
like kind of crappy so is this like
really shitty room with no windows and
like weird carpet on the ground and it
was really small I mean it was like like
really really really small and we have
this like easel and like a shitty light
and I was like so are we going to die
are we going to reduce our burn to 100k
a month so we have five months of runway
are we gonna break even or get
unprofitable and you know I knew what I
wanted but as CEOs like I need to make
sure everyone else wanted the same thing
everyone says we want to be profitable
and I said all right well we got to
write down all the things we can do to
make money and all the things we can do
to save money until we have enough of
these things and so about two hours we
just wrote down everything we invented
new ad units to figure out how to roll
video ads out the other side we cut a
lot of costs and then for the next month
we just did those things and we told
everyone what everyone in the company of
the cast situation and we told everyone
if we became profitable and made over
50k of profit we would take the whole
company to Hawaii seems like an easy bet
within two months we were break-even at
the end of that year we had generated
over 1.2 million dollars in profit
and we took the whole company to Hawaii
we took 25 people to why that spring but
kind of having gone through that we were
actually pretty proud of ourselves to be
completely honest we were like you know
and our company was probably making on
the order of eight to ten million
dollars in revenue it was like we might
have a company and this guy named Gideon
you
Kym's by the office I think we'd only
met with him a couple times and back
then he was working at Khosla he used to
work at Facebook and YouTube and
everywhere is kind of a big-shot guy and
he basically said what we had done was
useless our company sucked what we
accomplished was nothing and within
three years no one will ever heard of us
and we it was like a how [ __ ] okay we
were pretty proud like a minute before
he came in the office so we decided to
start thinking about some new ideas and
we came up with this thought that maybe
justin.tv and its revenue could fund
internal projects within the company
that could become the next generation of
what we were gonna do so that was the
beginning yeah that was the beginning of
everything so what were maybe talk a
little bit about some of those projects
could I know that you know this sort of
leads to a change in direction for the
company yeah there were all kinds of
projects they were we wanted to do deals
with TV networks there was we want to do
live event broadcasting in music
broadcasting yada yada yada but two
projects basically one one was Instagram
for life for Instagram for video not
live video because the iPhone this
sounds really old but the iPhone I guess
three had just come out and it supported
video natively for the first time before
we can only take photos with your iPhone
so we saw an opportunity there and we
saw Instagram kind of slowly becoming a
thing and then the other idea was to
become a site for people broadcasting
video games which people had actually
done on justin.tv for years and we had
just completely ignored them so we
basically split the company up into
three groups and we said for the next
six months we're gonna work on these
things we want to launch them and
basically achieve this growth rate month
over a month after six months we'll see
whether we succeed and we'll kill the
project that doesn't succeed so that
became justin.tv gaming which became
twitch the website and then Socialcam
the app and now this is like when
there's two versions of this story right
so version one of the story is that both
apps were doing
great so what do we do the real version
is that twitch was doing great and
Socialcam sucked horrible nobody was
using it but it's kind of a weird point
in the company because at that point
we've been doing justin.tv for about
five years and video gaming was really
Emmett's like baby and you know I like
games but like I wasn't that excited
about it
whereas mobile was something that I was
super excited about so yeah justin.tv
became a very different company very
quickly we decided because we had all
had vested all the founders invested at
Justin TV and twitch was basically just
an extension of Justin TV that we were
going to spin Socialcam out with Justin
TV and Justin decided that he wanted to
start another company so suddenly Justin
TV is twitch social cam and this company
called exact which was like a TaskRabbit
competitor and Justin and I find
ourselves in Y Combinator a lot older a
little wiser in the winter of 2012 cool
so talk a little bit more about that
transition I think from going from being
an operator to you know partner at YC
like why did you make that decision how
did you sort of think about that
decision and then you know sort of what
what have you learned since becoming a
partner I didn't want to join Y
Combinator actually basically what
happened after I did YC is within six
months we had sold Socialcam for 60
million dollars and I was getting ready
with my co-founders from Socialcam to
start another company we want to create
something that was going to be Palantir
for the developing world which actually
that kind of company just went through
YC so we covered and at that point
Sam was transitioning into running YC
and peih-gee was stepping back and so
Sam came to visit me at my office and he
said he wants you to join YC and I had
been a part-time partner I had you know
time advising companies I'd voted on
applications for years but I didn't
really want to do it
I had this cool idea for the next
company but he started talking about how
he was going to change Y say and kind of
what the vision was and how you know why
is he up to this point had been kind of
an incubator and accelerator or however
you want to call it but he was trying to
figure out how we can make sure YC stays
around for the next hundred years and a
lot of things would be different the
equity structure would be equal amongst
partners and we would do we would grow
it try to make it better and so I
thought to myself okay well I'm 30 X I
was 30 31 sold the company maybe want to
settle down this might be a better job
to do with the family and so I decided
to join YC but I told him I couldn't
start right away because I had already
planned a five-month trip around the
world with my girlfriend and so we
traveled on the world I got engaged and
then I started our YC she was pissed
because right around when I was getting
engaged I had to read YC applications
and actually right when we got married I
had relocations too so being on the I
guess being on the other side of the
table now as a partner at YC and then
having gone through it in the you know
11 years since what do you think has
changed most about YC and then maybe
talk a little bit about where YC is
going as just like as an organization I
think the YC program that most people
know now is for companies that are much
later stage than it was when I went
through and to address this we created
another program called the fellowship
which gives a smaller amount of money
but it's kind of focused on earlier
stage companies so that's been a big
change it's certainly bigger this last
batch was 126 companies the alumni are
far more useful you know we have 250 I'm
sorry we have 2,500 alumni now and so
just our alumni have done everything and
that's extremely valuable we invest in
many different areas so you know we were
really software focused when I went
through and you know now there's
Hardware biotech there was a satellite
company in the last batch there was a
supersonic plane in the last batch
cancer
stuff I mean all kinds of stuff which i
think is really exciting so a lot of
changes there and it's weird because
it's I think what I didn't realize when
I was a founder was I never quite
understood the feeling of being pitched
like I was always doing the pitching and
like it was funny because at YC I just
finished interviews right so we
interviewed 425 companies over the last
two weeks and so in a day you just sit
in a room and like every 10 minutes a
new company comes in and I think the
thing that I realized that I didn't
realize as a founder is I didn't most
people don't know how to say what their
company does like just like this like
the simplest thing like the first 10
words out of their mouth are not
understandable by humans and it's crazy
because it's like you know everyone's
focused on like the buzz words and the
action verbs and the it's like this for
this and I'm just like I don't know what
it like I and I'm smartish right I mean
I just don't know what it is and so so
much of what we do at YC is just get
people to like figure out how to say
like what it is that they do like how
not to use jargon
and it's funny because during YC we tell
other companies like two things we say
one there will be people in your batch
you know they're about 350 founders per
batch now there'll be people in your
batch will be in your wedding which like
no one ever believes us but there were
four YC people in my wedding like in the
actual like wedding party and then the
second thing we tell them is that you
are going to become the double-oh-seven
version of yourself like whatever you
are now like you're going to become the
James Bond version of that and like part
of that is like being confident saying
simple things and like being confident
not always like selling like just
describing and seeing if the person is
interested and it's so much fun to see a
transformation because in three months
people go from just kind of being
nervous pitchers to being more
but in describers obviously big theme of
this conference is changing face of tech
and diversity
how does my company to think about
diversity amongst founders amongst your
groups and then what are you doing maybe
as an organization invest in sort of
encouraging more diverse founders to to
build companies diversity here basically
sucks horribly and unfortunately
everyone is being compared to like the
corporate folks who are probably the
worst at it so it's like weird because
YC numbers are better than Google's but
the Google's numbers are so bad it's
like how do you even compare yourself to
that or Apple yeah it's tough
so basically YC numbers are 10% of our
founders or they're black or Hispanic
and 10% of our founders are women and a
large number of our founders
international over 20 25 percent are
international basically a lot of what we
do on that front is making sure people
understand that doors open because ycs
already structured so you don't have to
know us 75% of the companies that come
through YC did not receive a
recommendation we've never spoken to
we've never heard of until we read their
application and so it's already
structured right it's not like you have
to have a warm intro but I still think
people are intimidated to apply and so
I've done a lot of things around college
tours we've done a lot of things around
what we call open office hours where
anyone can come and get office hours
with us regardless of whether they're in
YC or they think they're ready or
anything like that and then the other
problem that we see in kind of
underrepresented communities is a
challenge in getting the first check and
so a lot of what we focus on in
fellowship is you don't have to have
anything you know we're writing a team a
twenty thousand dollar check and they
don't have to have any users or any
revenue or any product and we don't mind
being the catalyst for those things
being created so yeah we're trying a lot
of stuff on that front and I'm probably
forgetting a couple things but it's like
definitely shitty I'll ask one last
question and then open it to the
audience um so what are your I think you
touched on this briefly but maybe just
what are your top three pieces of advice
for entrepreneurs you were starting
companies right now or who may be in the
audience
top three pieces of advice if you don't
have a technical co-founder I really
probably don't want to talk to you at
all the way you split the equity amongst
your teammates indicates how you value
your teammates not who started first or
whose idea was it or who gave the first
25,000 so you really need to have a
justification for why your equity split
is equal is not equal or close to equal
most justifications are not good and you
impress me with what you do not your
resume so really it's just about how
much you've done in the small amount of
time you've been doing your startup if
you need money or some outside the thing
to make your company go then that's not
interesting those things sound really
rough but like a lot of people used to
lie to me when I first came to the
valley and do these things like that
sounds really interesting keep me
updated or like oh that sounds like a
really hard problem like tell me more
and then not answer emails and what I
always promise founders like I will tell
you the honest truth and like if you
know the bar and you choose not to meet
it well then that's on you like this is
the NBA most people don't make it but
we're not doing any service if we don't
tell you what the bar is that and then
we're just liars so that's the bar
Thanks
any audience questions don't ask me hard
questions
got a question anyone have a question
I'm gonna go ahead and start then so
Michael said that pictures are really
important you got to be able to pitch
what you do and maybe the first ten
words who here said that of a start-up
you have a start-up do you have a
start-up where the startup your chance
to pitch a white cow I know my I this
isn't really a pitch but this is
basically Michael you have to be able to
scribe what you're doing ten words so
let's say we're at a cocktail session
whatever what do you do for a go comics
is the first freemium streaming model
for comic books like a Spotify for
comics so I kind of know what that is
but I don't really know what that it's
try again like imagine that you were
like I didn't know what streaming was or
Spotify was or any of those things they
do yeah a free app for free comics a
little bit more ad-supported to start
subscription-based later a lot of
interest amongst Hollywood studios as a
content platform that can provide great
new content for TV and movies I don't
know about that part so maybe if I were
to pitch it back to you it sounds like
you're building is it a website or an
app great you want to say that so you're
building an app oh I didn't hear that
part sorry okay so you're building an
app that allows people to read comic
books for free beautiful and then like
what's the business part other than the
business parts ads just start what's it
going to be subscription rights
management fiction for who readers okay
so it's free to read a couple anomic
books but then they have two subjects
right now is 190 series in 600 books all
free independent creators smaller
publishers a few larger publishers Ren
talked with some very large publishers
okay but we haven't really long we were
in beta but we haven't really launched
for audience yet cool so I think they're
like that sounds awesome I think that
like I always tell people like for the
initial pitch pitch it as if you were
describing what the users experience is
that's like the best way of doing it so
like an app where user opens up their
app can read comic books and do bla bla
bla bla bla like
that's kind of like the most basic
construction and it sounds almost simple
but like simples fine I'm a simple guy
should we do another one yeah alright
who else has a start-up you guys is your
chance to picture strapped to a roomful
of jelly's and investors after
hesitating I'm not sure why you're here
no I guess I should also mention why is
he still accepting companies for this
batch oh wow this is actually this this
could be real stuff here we're making
stuff happen here good thing you came
here today hi I'm Ashley we have an
annotation tool that allows you to name
your company critique it sorry start
with that all right
I'm Ashley companies called critique it
we have an annotation tool that allows
you to embed audio and video and
documents of any type and have threaded
asynchronous conversations it's pretty
good when you say documents of any type
okay well I said that's even more
confusing good is there a type of
document you think people really want to
do this with yeah our primary user base
right now is in education so term papers
dissertations we also work with three
police departments there we go I would
start with I would send that or maybe do
like a for example for our current users
are yada yada yada yeah coz documents of
any type like that's like one of the
tricks here is like you want me to ask a
really engaged question back to you
which means I have to like understand
exactly what you do and then care and
like with documents of any type
I found myself asking me the question
like what does that mean and that was
blocking me from like caring and asking
question back because I was like a
tockman's it like is it like Word
documents is it news stuff like what is
it policy papers contracts yeah great
that's the kind of stuff where you want
to put that in there otherwise that's
very good thank you yeah I guess I
should keep on getting higher this is
like so from so far it seems like make
sure you say the name of your company
my company there's X don't give him she
don't give them hints okay sorry I'm
trying to be a supportive you know this
will just keep you on the hot spot so
we've had three workers so far we need
some woman in diverse people do it so
I'm the founder of relation box it's an
AI powered chat bot that helps people
improve their relationships that
definitely needs a second sentence so I
kind of get that what's your second
service like give me an example of how a
person has it do it during the day so
you can send a message to the bot and it
will communicate with you learn about
you and then it will give you advice and
feedback on your dating life and on your
relationships and how to improve them
that second sense is very helpful that's
a good one yeah all right - that's good
one very very comp at higher bass has a
startup okay dorri can you stand up you
have 15 seconds dear doctor Dora dot-com
a digital mental health startup that
will teach coping skills that are as
effective as psychiatric medications but
don't know what that means
uh-huh so try again okay
a digital mental health startup that
doesn't you don't need any of that okay
yeah to your site and what do they do
people can access online communities
webinars track progress through programs
and like the one thing you want them to
do learn skills to let's say treat their
own mood or anxiety disorders know
through um learning and instead of
spending seventy billion dollars a year
on psych meds
the kind of a site where people come and
they do activities that help them treat
their anxiety issues as opposed to using
medication yes and they'll if we were to
say activities let me say for example
for example one of the $20 and be parts
of groups to support for groups webinars
and and there will be a way for them to
track their progress in learning
certain skills and I'm gonna make that a
lot more specific but I like the general
thing right site where you come to learn
skills to help you treat your own mental
health issues without taking medicine we
have like these types of activities and
then like you can go on but like that is
great thank you
alright so do is it's okay
alright cool Amy is this like I'm a
machine with this I'm doing this for the
best deal hi I'm Amy Xuan I'm the CEO of
nano forma we have a better way of
delivering cancer drugs to tumors we use
nanotechnology that's been just
developed can't do that oh okay so
that's like what exactly does it do you
do what exactly we use this technology
what exactly happens to describe simply
we have a better way of creating drug
delivery products or drugs or drug
loading maybe try this like compare and
contrast so like are you creating drugs
yes or no we are attaching or you're
putting drugs into very tiny capsules
that get into the tumor more effectively
that sounds great
make sure you save hard do you say what
you do not yeah both people have these
flowery words around them just get to
the point I by the way like
nanotechnology is like we like screen
for buzzwords like machine learning ai
nanotechnology like all of those
buzzwords like we just don't care like
it's like like and when you use one of
those buzzwords the person listening to
you like if they're really experienced
investor they'll just stop thinking for
five seconds because they'll be mad so
like you just don't have to say like
tiny capsules sounds so stupid right
through the educated person but like it
worked so well we can do this somewhere
we can do some general questions what
you want to do is what I do general
questions are more mini pitches I take
people question question okay I just
have a question about we were talking
about diversity and this is a hard
question
I'm wondering if you're familiar with
the studies done by Harvard Business
School and elsewhere where there were
hit pitches done by men versus women and
the voice was hidden and the statistics
were stunning in front and showing that
pitches made in a male voice if the
exact same fish mate made in a male
voice was accepted I think 60 percent
over with a woman's voice ditto
I believe african-american pitches with
different voices and basically that's my
question
what sort of I'm just interested in what
your thoughts are about that and why why
you think that might be I think we all
know why that is I mean it's because
sexism and racism exists in the world so
I think that there are like two
approaches to it and there's a whole
group of people who are trying to make
sexism and racism not exists in the
world and like I love that and like I
celebrate them and I donate and I try my
best to help them and then I think
there's a different group of people who
are trying to help people succeed in a
sexist and racist world and like that's
kind of where I operate so what I tell
all of my minority founders is like for
your entire life to get to where you are
right now you've had to be better than
80% of the people in the room and like
actually if you're in a liberal
environment and you're better than 80%
of the people in the room there's some
benefits to being a minority but you
have to hit that bar so I just tell them
that's the bar and like it's not a
foreign bar it's not foreign for women
either and I feel as though what I tell
them is like no matter who's preaching
meritocracy that's not the world we live
in right now so like hit that bar 99.99%
of startups fail so being better than
80% of the room it still means you're
probably gonna fail and so you have to
be comfortable in the startup world with
failure that's got to be something where
you're just like man like those that's
okay like I've got good backup options
so it's much harder question to answer
like how do I get sexism racism out of
the world I do think if people see
people being successful who look
different like that helps and like I
think that like the place that I'm in in
this kind of world means that like I can
help people succeed in this world but I
don't really have good tools to like for
Sequoia to hire black people like the
press is really good at that
there are a lot of activists that are
really good that I don't have ability do
that I do have the ability to say
Sequoia this is an amazing minority
founder and like they're growing faster
than everyone else in the room they're
smarter than everyone else in the room
we found them you don't have to find
them we've already found them
you should fund them so that's kind of
how I think about it but it does suck
the current state of affairs not great
like totally agree you can either do a
pittance like a pitch or ask a question
nice your choice you know the general oh
yeah we're going to startup you to have
a button
I is general question and I think it's
something that weighs a lot on the minds
especially of early career
jelly's with a liberal arts background
and probably liked the idea of being an
investor where you get till it dabble in
a lot of different fields but the idea
being an operator and like startup
founder where you do one thing for
several years and if you get distracted
you fail that's very scary and what I
like about your story is it sounds like
you mmm
fill and fell into entrepreneurship
maybe you were sort of downplaying like
your okay that's pretty accurate okay so
you said you fell into entrepreneurship
and it worked out and now you see a lot
of other like budding entrepreneurs and
a lot of them don't work out and some of
them do work out so this is the nature
versus nurture type question right like
is it that you have what it takes kind
of thing what are some factors that can
contribute to a Yalie who has like many
different interests to succeed in doing
one thing well for the amount of years
it takes I think there's like I don't
want to generalize this but I think that
um when I went to my 10-year reunion I
was a little bit surprised because Yale
pitches that it's collected the best and
the brightest but I didn't see people I
saw extremely intelligent people but I
saw them when they were investing an
hour of their time they weren't
producing I think the work that they
would want to in that hour and I feel as
though what's weird is that like I
didn't feel like I ever got any guidance
on like what to do when I graduated and
I kind of fell into a startup and then
it was like oh we're gonna die we're
gonna die we're gonna die and so I ended
up working really hard on one thing for
like eight years because it was almost
about to die the whole time and then it
turned out that working really hard on
one thing worked right I had a lot of
friends who thought that their 20s was
the time to discover their life and
their world views and to taste a bunch
of different jobs but all of them now
are like early 30s and
a lot of the doors that would have been
open to them are closed family expenses
where they decided to live like all of
these things are a lot more a lot less
plastic than they were when they were 23
so I do feel like for folks who are at
all interested in startups the one thing
I tell them is like start absolutely
right now and anyone on the liberal arts
side is kind of in a [ __ ] situation
because there were points at justin.tv
where I felt like if we failed it
wouldn't be easy for me to find another
job I think anyone who's an engineer
though it's like an infinite safety net
but anyone whose CS major if they're not
selling a company it's just silly
it's probably like literally the revenue
maximizing thing to do because if the
company fails they'll get a better job
it would ever tech company they want to
work at afterwards because they've shown
the ability to do all these things for
us liberal arts people yeah I mean we
chose the easy way so it should be one
more risk if you don't have to wake up
and go to Science Hill or the
engineering lab in the morning yeah it
was a lot harder so yeah I mean but to
answer your question I think it's that
we're not telling people like there's no
career anything at Yale and so like you
just kind of get out there and then you
operate on like some of the same
theories that you use to choose colleges
and when my brother's human colleges
right now and it's like funny what high
school kids to think about college cuz
they're just like oh that's not true but
you know it's what they think so yeah so
I think that's kind of where I would
address it like I really wish there was
a better way to understand the options
my senior year passed like oh you should
just go to this consulting thing or the
side making thing and hopefully get a
job but it's hard for me to say everyone
should go all-in right cuz like most
people don't succeed that's really hard
for me to say but if you want to do
startups it's not kind of dabbling game
alright that kristin is an som grad who
has a little company she wants to tell
you about a craft right it went I know
it's a little one right now it's a it's
a business plan right now is what it is
it's called outpost and it's a seasonal
pop-up hotel for outdoor sports
enthusiasts
where do you so I like that description
but it definitely needs like the second
sentence so like I don't know what a
pop-up hotel is this is a hotel that
would be based on mobile lodging units
so this could be like air streams your
so I would use my second tends to be an
example like so for example during the
winter at Vail we roll up a bunch of RVs
mobile use data and we can offer the
ability for you to go skiing and pay
much less for your hotel than the other
options whatever like but that's good
you have a technical co-founder or do
you write code executive co-founder yes
and was not yet ah there are many many
really smart people we went to school
together I don't have a pitch but I will
stand up again actually I did sort of
have an idea of like oh that's the best
way to start an investor pitch right way
this is I don't have it tactical I don't
have a technical person so I lose but I
do think Airport parking sucks and so if
there were like ballet Airport parking
that went and drove your car like 30
minutes away where it's free to park and
then track your flight and brought your
car right back to you as soon as you got
out like uber for car parking but you
call that good all this like flight car
oh is that what that is yeah okay
my question really was can you what was
the other idea that you had
that you couldn't do because he went to
Y Combinator and then can you pitch that
and Y Combinator back to us yeah yeah
never a roast pitch the first pitch
you've got three questions in their
bread and you're very slick so the idea
I wanted to work on was I wanted to
build software for developing countries
to help them develop and it is that a
lot of people think people who run these
countries are corrupt but perhaps if
they had a better set of software better
sort of tools even while being corrupt
they would be better at running their
country developing it and helping their
citizens and so that's why I called it
kind of like Palantir for developing
countries because it's like selling
software to governments so that's that
one YC I don't know well I see a shitty
started Thank You Manila I mean
so why seize a three-month program that
startups can apply to and its mentor
startups gives them access to a huge
alumni database helps them fundraise and
then continues to support them for the
next 7 to 10 years of their life and we
invest a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars in each startup and in return
receive 7% for the startups that truly
do well we have a new fund to call it
the continuity fund which allows us to
invest in them in the later stages whoo
that's nice so you had the name you had
with who the customers are and you had
the benefits that most a couple time you
just want to run a pitch by you so
training mobile networks is an app on
Android and iOS
that gives users faster cheaper and more
more reliable connections by combining
Wi-Fi cellular and mesh connections to
improve Wi-Fi coverage and connectivity
it's kind of cheating as I know what
your company does but I did understand
that very well so yes that's good all
right you want to another one
okay what to say if you're pitching a
different startup that would be very
weird so I'm from the Bay Area and you
guys are way too successful what you do
and your companies have raised way too
much money and you're paying your
employees way too much and rent is super
high and you guys just launched a really
interesting program on universal basic
income and I'd be curious to just hear
more about that why you guys decided
that you wanted to do that and how you
have observed and your your perspective
on how San Francisco has evolved over
time and what we can do to be better and
to make it more diverse and inclusive so
I might blame like Google and Apple and
those guys I guess we might have a part
in that so part of Y Combinator's goal
is to kind of start to become what we
would think of as the next generation of
a university and it's weird because the
core of it is vocational and not liberal
arts which actually think something that
Yale needs to really consider but their
other kind of parts of kind of this
university idea and one of the one of
those parts is research one of the ideas
is that not only should we be supporting
things that maybe can happy in the next
two or three years but we should
supporting technologies that maybe take
ten or fifteen years or experiments and
we take 10 or 15 years to figure out and
so YC research is supporting a couple AI
teams as a result and also this type of
project and I think that in the way we
thought about it was you know we're in
the unique position to run an experiment
in a non academic setting which means
that like we can fund it and we don't
have to deal with like university
[ __ ] so why don't we just do it and
then like instead of having an argument
on like the philosophy or the morality
around universal basic income maybe we
can also incorporate real data also we
kind of thought it'd be really cool to
do it in America because Universal
basically I'm such a weird thing like
you're do in a place like Norway or
Sweden where everyone basically is the
same ethnicity there's a lot more public
support
helping someone who looks like your
brother then there is helping somewhere
it doesn't look like your brother and so
we kind of felt like it was important to
get data here reflecting kind of the
fact that us is a different place so
yeah that's actually every sentence I
know about the project we have a
question from rich who is one of the
chairs of Yale tech New York thanks for
coming today
awesome thank you having me so my
question is pretty simple what do you
what do you think venture capital looks
like in ten years what's gonna change
from you know how it works all today
that's oh it's so much easier for me to
answer how it's changed over the last
ten years so I'll give you two options
how about that I think either the trend
will continue where VC funds get larger
have to write bigger checks and end up
investing later stage and a lot more
money comes in with the smaller funds
and angels earlier so basically it's
like the removal of the series a today's
series a is 5 10 years ago Series B and
so one trend is that that just solidly
continues and you don't see companies
raising series days until they actually
look like real companies YC that's the
experience for most YC companies most YC
companies will raise between 1 and 3
million dollars from angels or angel
funds and they won't be talking to
Series A investors for the first two
years of their life the alternative is
that these micro funds thrive and the
big VC funds see them is competitive in
which case in that case the big VCS will
want to come back jump in earlier start
doing many more 10 15 20 million dollar
valuation deals as opposed to the 40 to
100 they do
now and then they'll have to figure out
how to scale because fundamentally you
know YC has to support hundreds of
companies a year and if you're in the
angel game you just have to be able to
write a lot smaller tracks to a lot more
companies the one reason why I think
it's gonna be very very hard to do is
because VC funds with big brands have a
really big problem of selecting winners
early and so you know if you're an
entries in Horowitz and you select lifts
in you know month seven and that
prevents you from getting uber you just
kind of [ __ ] yourself so it's unclear
how they're gonna be able to figure that
piece out so if I were betting I
probably been on on a I probably bet on
VC funds continue to go later much more
money comes in this kind of early stuff
that money is a lot more founder
friendly and basically most things die
before they ever have to pitch a VC I
like that not because I don't like VCS
it's just that like you know the money
is easier to raise it's faster they're
less owners terms and like most things
should die early we have just a few
minutes left so I want to actually go
into a quick pitch around like once the
dense 15 seconds pitch will do a lot of
them rapidly and they just do a cup of
words like thumbs up like it same or
whatever how about that they're more
people who want to pitch well when I
asked that there were startup founders
in the room about earlier in the day
about two-thirds of the people raised
their hand when it comes out in pitch
only like three people wanted to raise
their hand
so I don't quite get the math on that so
they get people are shy or just need
practice so anybody want to want to
pitch all right quick I actually think
you under so what YC could do okay
pitch my C just give you a feedback on
that not sure how that adds any value
but by all means let's do it
just cares what I do pitch so my name is
Davis I workout Y Combinator we help
empower and entrepreneurs to change how
the world works by giving them mentors
to guide them your credibility to
attract people to help them and a food
so they don't starve on the streets
it sounds great alright that's my joke
quick pitch or just see like why don't I
just
final question that really is awesome Oh
make us all go that was an awesome
question okay Matt I like the pressure
so hey what would you invest in today
and both in terms of what's gonna make
you the most money and also what's the
what just should we invest in and how do
we bridge that gap see it's hard for me
to answer that like with one thing I
think I'm like starting to as I've
started to invest more personally by the
way why is he investing is pretty
different
you know 6,000 companies we just try to
draw a circle around 100 and pray that's
why I say when you have to put your own
money down then things start getting all
more interesting and I feel like there
are different filters and certain things
get caught in my filters so one is a
flow filter if any of my friends start
companies I'm going to invest because
god forbid they become billion-dollar
companies that I didn't invest if I'd
apply that rule for a minute one I'd be
a thousand times wealthier right now so
that's one rule I think the second rule
is like I do like startups that are
doing hard technical things like I think
like the one cool thing that Elon Musk
has done has been able to show you that
like cool tech things can still be done
in the world.the in cars and rockets and
stuff so I like that kind of stuff
there's kind of a general YC thesis
around replacing the entire back office
like everything that used to be
Microsoft Oracle s ap like that stuff
used to be the modern stuff and the
stuff used at home used to be [ __ ] and
now that stuff just looks disgusting and
the stuff you use at home is like super
modern and updating all the time and so
I think that like all the back office
stuff is basically up for grabs in a way
that it hasn't been before what else
the other is how I invest as opposed to
what I think what I've learned more than
anything I've gone through different
cycles of writing angel checks my
current thesis is that if I'm not
willing to put an amount of money in
that causes me a little bit of pain then
it's not a real investment and so I
basically 10x the amount of money I
invest per deal and it feels like it
feels shitty I mean it feels like I'm
just throwing 10x to the money down the
drain
but also it like I feel like it
clarifies the decision because I don't
feel sorry for the comp like I'm not
going to invest in $50,000 because I
feel sorry for the company or cuz like I
think it makes the world a better place
like I'm gonna do it because I hope I
can get that back and so I think that's
been a big change in my approach as well
that's all I got
with that I want to thank Michael for
coming out to talk with us